antaño conocida por sus viñedos bakúdes
ahora llamadas sombría mente la picadora
de carne porque la guerra de trincheras
aquí entre soldados ucranianos y fuerzas
rusas está destrozando o matando a
cientos de personas diariamente los
socorristas y aventuran a salir al
frente haciendo lo mejor que pueden para
ayudar
las lesiones más comunes son las
producidas por la explosión de minas por
los bombardeos de artillería y por los
morteros en cuanto a las lesiones
producidas por combates directos cabeza
cabeza solo nos llega un porcentaje
menor por lo general hasta el 90% de las
heridas se deben a las minas y
explosivos
situada en una ruta estratégica de
suministro para kiev y sus alrededores
se han convertido en epicentro de
brutales combates en los últimos seis
meses la mayoría de los 70.000
residentes han huido a medida que se han
ido a zonas más seguras los equipos
médicos se han apresurado a ayudar a los
soldados heridos tengo la sensación de
que me ayuda es necesaria Y si salva la
vida de al menos un soldado que luego se
incorpora las filas Entonces mi trabajo
no fue en vano
pero los soldados y los médicos
ucranianos pagan un alto precio rodeados
de una guerra tan intensa
lo más difícil para mí para cualquier
médico es cuando un soldado herido
fallece siempre es difícil Incluso en
tiempos de paz Cuando los pacientes
mueren ahora aún más porque esta persona
está sana y luego acaba de morir
los médicos y soldados han sido
desplegados a bakú desde el frente sur y
gerson aunque adoptan una actitud
valiente dicen que los combates aquí son
más brutales que cualquier cosa que
hayan visto antes